I'm here at the Lucasfilm compound at
the Presidio in San Francisco this is a
place where they literally manufacture
magic and Wonder as you can see there's
a statue of Yoda right here Yoda is 900
years old so as you can see he has a
bladder control problem he I must
[Music]
[Applause]
this is John sang hi John how are you I
do welcome here we have some of the
original costumes from the from the
movies this is incredible now this I
don't know a lot about Star Wars this is
Darth Vader is that correct
this is Darth Vader yes looks like
there's a retractable door here look
like that yes push I think it's this
button good to see you Jordan is our
resident Star Wars expert is that fair
to say Jordan yes sir
Jordan you have some problems with this
Darth Vader costume well I just never
said John it said it was an original and
then I also noticed that the chest plate
doesn't have the Hebrew lettering in
these three areas that the original has
which led me to believe that maybe it
actually is a replica it probably is
so earlier when you said you think this
is the original I they were lying to me
and Darth Maul actually specializes in
musical theater is that right I'm gonna
Wow yeah this is he's a bounty hunter
yeah and he has some some brave what
some Jedi what is their brains from the
Jedi that he's killed Jordan do you note
any inaccuracies with the Boba Fett
costume well Jon the one thing that you
mentioned that again I questioned was
you would call these Jedi braids I had
always heard of them referred to as
wookie braids in us in a shot for his
chest as he heard of Nivea cream look at
his arm
four million light years it's a long
trip okay you just said four million
light years
Jordan would you step in please ago yeah
what is it yeah it's actually six
million light years
Dragonslayer and one of the other cool
things we have one of the original lips
is from Indiana Jones do you mind if I
is it okay
yeah oh wow look at that whoa did you
hear that
look at that Wow
I just whipped myself in the back one of
the original imperial power hold yeah
it's so cool yeah I remember those those
want the empire spread yeah I love the
way these things were sort of disliked
things may have the wrong problem is
this part needs to go in here to get
that tab in
this is industr this is Industrial Light
and Magic they're pretty much the
biggest visual effects company in in the
entertainment industry you mind if we
come in for sec nope don't mind at all
this is our nerd corner here nerd corner
you said it I didn't hi what is your
name my name is Charles hey Charles
really good to meet you
what is this fan for this is this is so
you never have to go outside that's
right really what it would be like if
you took ten steps and walked outside
absolutely Kevin I want to ask you
quickly about your professional
wrestling failures what's that all about
basically my my folks just wanted them
to get out of the house Big John Studd
yes yes and I was like oh I'll take
these I know exactly where those things
right were they worried that you have a
vast collection of men without shirts
Maya - Maya Kaiser let me ask you
something what is the male to female
ratio here I've walked around a ratio I
think is 800 to 1
I just wanted you to keep my friend
that's my friend Charles I thought you
two should meet
hi
[Music]
this is Mike Sanders is that right we're
gonna do is turn this place into a
virtual studio and you're gonna author
the performance of some digital
creatures and to do that I need to get
into a special it's a it's a humbling
lycra suit
why you say humbling we're gonna find
out
[Music]
[Applause]
this was a mistake
we're gonna plug you right into the
first digital character we've got here
it's a demo character we call the schwa
the schwa the schwa oh here he is yep
this is the schwa right here so I am now
the schwa yeah exactly is the shot schwa
been in any Star Wars movies no okay
this is this is where the schwa gets the
phone call that he's not good enough for
Star Wars he's been cut well what it's
crazy I'm perfect for it what do you
mean oh wise they think I have an eating
disorder I'm just I totally am right for
that POW forget it woody no I'm calling
these characters from the Star Wars
episodes great an actual Star Wars
character cool let's do that oh cool
c-3po even I know c-3po rocquette c-3po
sir is there a Star Wars film I haven't
seen them all where c-3po turns into a
real badass
yes this is herniated disk c-3po right
here too many martinis c-3po
I'm okay
Chewbacca's saying you alright man you
really you had a lot to drink no okay
[Applause]
c-3po is you're on your set
[Music]
[Applause]
new iln people are fantastic I thank you
but before I leave this incredible place
there's something I must do excuse me
Kevin Charles come with me we're going
outside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you